expectations so what does that kind of
say about this this album where you're
at right now
like life in general I know you speaking
like these be kind of like I try to be
you're very you're very good interviewer
our charter you're like pour it all out
you're like what does I'm like what does
that mean you're like what was like I'm
basically asking when was the last time
you had sex
and a coded form
[Music]
the fast lanes in canal only
expectations for me was about you know
growing up and watching like all like
the fairy tales and all the kid channels
and like wanting to be a princess and
thinking that love was like a fairy tale
and that you'd go to Hollywood and you'd
become famous right off the bat and make
millions of dollars and boom and then
and then like you get to LA and you're
like went where but it's really me
telling myself in the world like telling
it like it's better to have no
expectations meaning like live in the
moment
because well you have a lot of
expectations I feel like it leads you to
getting let down so we'll survive it
besides no one tell you you're not
allowed to say I can say bye chalant
tell you he wants to Y me specifically I
don't know you don't trust me what you
know one name okay
I honestly forgot damn I forgot what the
guy's name was I have a song called
steady and then they sent it to Tory
Lanez and he put the most unbelievable
first on it like you know because
sometimes you do collaborations in there
and sometimes he said them out and then
see if somebody like likes it that's a
little bit like cooler like I'm not cool
or like less you know you don't to play
it with another person yeah like if you
don't like you like then whatever by but
I sent it to him and he loved it and
it's the probably one of the best verses
I've ever got
meant to be was a song that debuted at
number one on the Hot Country 100 which
is which is you know bill boys a lot of
times are dominated by males as a female
do you feel like a lot sometimes they're
underrepresented on the charts yes yeah
I think that now is the time where we're
being more empowered it's kind of my
like job and other female artists job
and songwriters to really like support
each other and to make room for all the
up-and-coming artists and songwriters
and let them know that there is room for
them I threw a dinner call women in
harmony that's great never heard of that
you haven't heard that is really nice I
invited all female writers to a dinner
and I took everyone out for the night
and it was like a whole room full of
like successful songwriters and we all
just sat there and talked about being
women in music that's actually amazing
yeah it was really cool